he's filtering the orange juice pulp
with his ghost hand dude that is cool i
want those this background 100 cg is
actually a pretty groundbreaking movie
in terms of visual effects this is
literally the screen effect yeah screen
effects
thanks to bessie for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can save 25 off your new pair of
shoes hey what's up everyone whoa we are
all back here for visual effects artist
react it is october and so the theme
this year is halloween
it's radical i know all right well let's
just jump in guys
[Music]
so what is this movie is it like a
stop-motion film yes i know it's tim
burton have you really never seen this i
really have never seen this i'm going to
consider stop-motion visual effects
because a lot of stop-motion is used for
visual effects there's a lot of visual
trickery in stop motion that's not your
traditional digital effect that you're
used to i mean those are some digital
leaves am i right you're probably not
actually i figured
this reminds me of james and the giant
peach pretty sure james the giant peach
is the same director no way this is an
awesome little intro
oh that's cool that shot there reminded
me of the wolf from neverending story
that's a creepy movie yeah we should
talk about that one soon dang dude the
swamp scene
[Music]
i'd rather not cry on this episode so
let's not
this is all captured in camera right
it's all just a bunch of photos stacked
together one after another because all
these little clay puppets and whatnot
are being molded frame by frame pretty
much the vast majority of what you're
gonna see is captured in camera there's
some trickery here and there what year
did this come out 1993 oh so this came
out the same year as jurassic park hey
look at that fire there wasn't a single
digital effect in that frame hold up
how are they doing that though is that
hand drawn animated or is that a
computerized digital effect see if you
guys can guess how they did the torches
okay here's my guess they filmed the
shot and then they just re-exposed the
same film while looking at a fire that's
close all right so i think they filmed a
fire element and they just went frame by
frame and overlaid it on top of the
other film yes you basically got it so
the way they did it you know you got all
your people posed they're holding
torches they'd have their one frame they
went through the whole shot they just
have the first frame they'd take a
little piece of paper to act as a movie
screen they'd stick it to the end of the
torch they'd turn off all the lights and
they'd project a little image of fire
onto that little piece of paper like
it's a little mini movie screen and then
do one more exposure on the piece of
film so you'd have a double exposure one
of the entire scene then one of just a
little image of fire this is literally
the screen effect yeah screen effect
[Applause]
yeah so it's cool to see that they
actually did the screen effect because
these days in say after effects you'll
have like your footage layer and then an
element layer let's say you recorded
flames against a black background but
you just need the flames not the black
background and the way to do it is you
just set it to screen or add or some
sort of transparency mode like that the
way it works is basically every pixel
within the footage gets applied in
number so a black pixel is actually zero
and a white pixel is 255 and so it just
takes those numbers and adds them to the
one below but if it's zero you can't add
zero to anything so you just end up with
the pixel that was below it your
original footage but fire on the other
hand is much brighter and because it's
so much brighter it carries through it's
insane how much easier it is for us now
with after effects and photoshop to be
able to do the things that would take
hours for these guys back in the day
which for us is just seconds
[Music]
and you have like the water there which
is a effect added afterwards just it's
another element that's been probably
composited in in this case digitally oh
wait
there's a mask line where he comes out
of the water there it's not moving you
can see yep it just holds static he just
came out of a hole yeah he just came out
the well there's no water in there yeah
rising out of it and then how are they
doing the drippy drops on them like that
that's just like probably wax or glue
just being moved down that's stop motion
yeah it has that stop-motion effect to
it that is some master animation it just
blows my mind too that these animators
have the foresight to like get the
perfect movement well they do have some
tools that help them achieve that this
is just when you're starting to have
things like video and some computer
frame playback so they would have a
video capture of their last frame or the
last couple frames and they could watch
it on video and go back and forth and
see the most recent frame to see if
everything was moving correctly and then
they wanted the movie to have like
natural flowing camera motion so you
have shots where the camera is moving
through a set the animator's like how do
we animate the puppets there's a camera
right here that's like bigger than my
body and so you know part of it is you'd
be suspended above poking down into the
set that's still not enough though they
actually set up a motion control rig so
motion control is basically where your
camera is robotically controlled in its
position so you can have it repeat the
exact same movement or go to the same
position so they'd have the camera doing
move and they would motion control to
leave the set come in
adjustments and the camera motion
controls back to the exact same spot
where it was awesome dude that sounds so
meticulous
[Music]
you guys have noticed how jack
skellington's face like animates really
smoothly one of the reasons for that is
using something called replacement
animation so a lot of stuff is just
you're just bending things right for
something like jack's face which has so
much expression the eyebrows like built
into his skull oh i know yeah so they're
using replacement animation where it's
just different head models that are
swapping to yeah they've just sculpted
all the head models beforehand and the
hard thing about all that is that you
have to sculpt every phoneme with all
your expressions so they actually made
the entire range of possible facial
animations and just had all of those
heads as a set and depending on the
scene and depending on the dialogue they
would pick and choose the correct head
yes except the picking and choosing
happened in a computer beforehand where
they had the recorded takes and they had
just the faces they went through and
frame by frame figured out what head
with which number they'd be using for
each frame dude that is cool i want
those i've got to know that you know it
is
this
what's the very first vfx shot that you
saw that blew your mind let us know in
the comments listen
cut the crap okay if you don't show
yourself right now i'm gonna have you
arrested for trespassing so two years
later a movie came out called casper hey
okay sheesh calm down lady
here
[Music]
[Applause]
hi i'm jasper it was actually the first
movie to ever have a full cg main
character that interacted with the other
live-action actors in the movie it's
also the first movie to have a cg
character with full expressive emotion
who thought casper would be like the
defining cg character historical moment
it's actually a pretty groundbreaking
movie in terms of visual effects there's
a lot of crazy stuff going on here let's
just take a look
[Music]
look at this though look at this this is
awesome that smug casper expression
sunny side up kind of makes me yak
no problem
whoa look at that he's filtering the
orange juice pulp with his ghost hand
yeah look at the pitcher too it's all
real yeah there's no fluid simulations
happening there so the pitcher with the
orange juice is obviously real the
orange juice itself pulling out of the
pitcher is obviously real but there is
some sort of interaction happening with
that hand there it's going through
something so you can see some artifacts
here that could help give us a clue as
to how the shot was done when he stops
pouring the orange juice just disappears
from his hand in a single frame but the
orange juice in the picture is still
pouring the pitcher and the cup are
separate elements so this would probably
be a motion control setup where the
camera is going to film this multiple
times it's going to repeat the same
exact movements you'll film a picture
element once you'll film your cup
element second and then probably get a
clean plate without anything just in
case you need it for casper could be
yeah give me
my
meal
[Applause]
okay okay wait are those those are
pieces of food cg they are cg food the
artist who worked on this shot said it
took him two months to finish this one
shot the mesh on that food was so dense
it required so much computer power that
is one of the most impressive shots i've
seen so far and i'm willing to bet
almost no one blinked an eye on it
that's hilarious that's so good yes
please got no respect for us after all
we've done for the little blower
hey
what the hell do you think you're doing
look at that there though we're looking
at real chunky food bits on the ground
while casper is holding a cg dust pan
with cg food on it cg food bits mixed in
with real food but you can't tell the
difference you know it's a good
testament once again to understanding
your lighting understanding your shaders
understanding what you can do well and
then shooting for that it also really
helps there's a very cg character right
next to it that's not supposed to look
real you know in contrast next to the
food and the pan and the broom look real
yeah your mind wants to make it work
it's like a magician good filmmaking see
at the time the state of the art cg
stuff was like dinosaurs but here we
have an actual character that's emoting
for the first time yeah yeah we take it
for granted that you can just animate a
cg character like you still have to
build the systems for doing so so yeah
they built a facial capture rig to build
out casper's main facial expressions and
then you'd have animators go back in and
specifically work on the lips and they
said it would take anywhere from two
weeks to three months to finish any one
of these shots depending on how
complicated the facial expressions were
and also there's three other ghosts too
in this movie the ghosts are obviously
dated the animation's a little bit dated
but i think the way they combined the cg
characters and the live action it was
groundbreaking for the time so the team
that worked on this was ilm and they
pretty much immediately rolled off of
doing this film which they thought was
really hard and they immediately went
into working on this movie called
flubber it's flubber
flubber sounds like baby shampoo the
scariest of movies lover traumatized me
as a child we did it really i couldn't
play with silly putty after that movie i
saw the black and white version first
actually there's a black and white
version of flubber yeah it's actually
arguably as good if not better than the
remake remake yeah flavor is a remake
you guys aren't aware the robin williams
version of flubber is a remake yeah
there's like flying cars and all stuff i
did not know that
i miss robin williams
[Music]
so this looks like a little abyss chrome
tentacle thing
yeah it's like the abyss but there's
bubbles in it now
it definitely looks like aloe vera and
what's funny is that they actually like
referenced a ton of different materials
like hair gel toothpaste and just
photographed it from a bunch of
different angles as inspiration for what
flubber should look like because slubber
is never actually practical in this
movie he is 100
cg every single time you see him okay
and
whoa
oh my god
oh my god that's a cool shot right yeah
all right i want to talk about that shot
really quick because that was not
planned really oh he just he just did
that so here's the thing about robin
williams he is considered an improv
master and so when he's just riffing
around on set he just decided you know
what what if i pretended to stretch it
and then shove my face into it and
there's vfx artists on set supervising
everything but the director was like yes
that was great they all have a heart
attack they did
because they didn't know what they were
especially because the director was like
yes we are definitely keeping that that
was great good job robin williams and it
took him three months to do that shot
really that one shot let's try and
describe you
uh you're an elastomer
um
so yeah the thing about animating
flubber is that he takes the shape of
multiple different objects so that was a
huge animation challenge now this is the
same team that was just coming off the
back of casper where it's these
amorphous physical objects that can't
take the shape of multiple things and
they had to apply it to this sort of
effect normally when you animate
something like a t-rex you have a rigged
system you know you have all these bones
and lines that you can actually move and
animate but with a little wiggly thing
like this you can't really use that same
sort of rigging system that you would
use on other projects so they had to
come up with a bunch of new stuff for
this and combine that with the fact that
you're having to render a transparent
and reflective object
[Music]
there's a lot of cool stuff going on
with this specific shot
[Music]
so that shot there where the camera is
moving around this background 100 cg
it's got to be no that that's practical
those wide shots yeah that looks
practical but even like the close-ups
same set i mean that could be real i
would at first assume that this is a cg
background but it is nicely detailed
they could have done it i don't know it
was done for real really on a miniature
set three times bigger
than what it actually was so here's the
problem they wanted to have these
sweeping camera moves but the set it was
too small for an actual camera to move
around so they had to literally scale up
the set three times and they actually
animated the camera moves on a computer
ahead of time and then translated that
to a motion control device to move the
camera through specifically how they
planned that's so much work for
something these days you'd just do the
entire set and see yeah no
exactly these days it would just be 100
cg but they couldn't do that back then
the level of fidelity with the cg
background wasn't good enough for what
they needed for this moment but here's
the thing they still had to make a cg
version of this set for all of the
reflections yeah and the refraction
through flubber everything that you're
seeing that's through flubber yeah is cg
oh my god
it's not like the rendering out flubber
that's slightly transparent and then
just putting it on the background yeah
what you're seeing that's refracting
through flubber yeah is the digital
recreation of this three times larger
set oh my god that's so meticulous so it
took a lot of work and effort just to
make that because it's one thing to have
a velociraptor that's opaque and it's
reflecting your scene but just the
lights but if you were to have like a
chromed out object now it's actually
reflecting imagery from your scene but
for it to also be transparent like
flubber is here with little air bubbles
in between that's also doing double
refractions and stuff like that it
requires so much effort to make that
look photo real dude this is so detailed
and this is just deep for this flubber
dance number for no reason
[Music]
these guys work really hard every single
day and they could use a little treat
maybe a little chocolate chip cookie
action so go ahead and subscribe if we
get a thousand subscribers from this
push right here these guys are getting
chocolate chip cookies next episode that
sounds really nice hey please subscribe
i'd like some cookies
i have been informed that we're about to
look at a goof
bird remember when we watched for a
democrat i do remember when we watched
birdemic
look at this dude man
i managed to go my whole life without
watching this
all the birds are like they're never
tracked it's like clip art this is very
clearly just
super low budget filmmaking so it's just
probably one director who's probably
also operating the camera and telling
the actors all right pretend birds are
attacking you and fight them off and as
an actor there's only so much you can do
you're like okay you're just assuming
that birds are going to be expertly
applied later
[Laughter]
okay here's the thing i bet you it was a
college student with his college buddies
saying i am going to make a film and you
guys are going to be in my film clint i
would agree with you if this weren't
shot in los angeles in fact this is like
an la thing it's definitely like we're
going to go and we're going to make a
movie i think we're on the same page
we're basically saying like it's serious
you gotta at a certain point you can't
make a feature film ironically isn't he
like a middle-aged asian dude if he was
intentionally trying to make this
ironically it wouldn't have been good it
became a cult classic because it's so
bad but he wasn't trying to make it bad
you know what good for him man i mean
yeah hey he made the movie look we can
be up front and say it's not a good
movie that's okay as an artist you're
gonna make bad stuff especially your
first damn detail i can't shake them get
them off my tail
it's gonna be bad you know what if you
wanna make movies your first one's not
gonna be good either it's gonna suck so
get it done and get it out make the
second one
i don't know about you but i've
struggled to find like a good pair of
shoes that i can just have on that are
comfortable for a while until i had a
pair of vessies bestie has a new pair of
shoes that they brought all of their
innovations to it's called the weekend
shoe so i've been rocking the white
weekend shoes for a while now it's
really comfortable it's 100 waterproof
so you can splash water all over it you
can do that thing where you put ketchup
on it rolls right off don't actually try
that because it's a waste of ketchup
they're like sand proof they're sludge
proof and they're super grippy so
they're like
slip proof what's also really neat about
these shoes is that they're 100 vegan
they're made out of this knitted
material that keep your feet comfortable
and they're breathable too so you know
you can keep cool in the winter or warm
in the summer wait dang it vessie has
everything you're looking for in a new
pair of shoes and i'm really enjoying my
pair so if you want to slip your feet
into a pair of these shoes go ahead and
click that link in the description we'll
save you 25 off your purchase but for
now
let's finish off this video that was fun
i really enjoyed this episode some
throwback movies here man watching
flubber just jiggle around it's really
satisfying kind of like those satisfying
renders that you maybe have seen on
instagram or reddit you know what we
actually did that we had a satisfying
render challenge we made a video about
it so go check it out if you haven't
it's hilarious watching these guys panic
as they try to make the most satisfying
render they can it was actually very
stressful
i just got to judge it i didn't have to
make them yeah you just got to be
satisfied and reap the benefits or was i
dissatisfied
check out the video to find out so long
everybody thanks for watching
until next time does anyone still wave
like this my daughter
actually she goes like this